yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing khari master back ever done
tomorrow reading to 390 oh my good
yeah anyhow what is he doing there
b3 it's a very solid line this is a good
reply you should have six I mean that's
not it's nothing special but it is
certainly quite interesting
it's a bit uncommon but the bishop is
making some pressure on the long
diagonal I'm going to go c5 shortly
probably next move
yeah I should attack the center we'll
see if we get a hanging pawn hanging
pawns formation or maybe after take C
will probably take with the piece no
actually goes for the more interesting
structure that's good makes it a bit
more interesting
yeah however I'm having some pressure on
d4 already currently I'm one idea can be
to take on c4 and just take D form I'm
currently threatening that so not sure
what it's going to do c5 I have b6 that
doesn't do anything good
hmm yeah well that cannot be or that
great that's a very convenient position
already if I take away the night taking
away the pawn might even be stronger to
be honest that makes this night on the
to end this Bishop won't be too greedy
silly you know that that is definitely a
very comfortable for me
okay try to isolate the c5 pawn isolate
meaning not that it is an isolated
permit can I'm trying to detach it let's
say from the rest of his forces that the
pawn is somewhat weak default of course
might also be similarly weak but yeah
what seem if sticks is useful giving me
a little bit of extra convenience for
for the King and 95 and so on that's
quite a number of though things that add
up that are useful yes so I'm going to
wrap this
[Music]
why does that work even and the check
okay just not lead to a win
take take check yeah I have a somewhat
better ending at the end but I don't
have a win don't win I'm overlooking
something that could that maybe still
wins that I don't see it looks very
dubious to take him don't see it don't
see it I mean I only see this currently
this favorable ending but this is not
favorable yeah
like winning but just a bit bit better
you know I'm still very dry
[Music]
you know that's extremely dry just one
day of this anything that I could try I
mean check him here I'm King Avery I
mean he's he doesn't have a square it
probably does not matter but yeah let's
see let's see
I mean King g6 I wanted to play anyway
so so in v h5 I guess h5
I can shake and play to that that will
win a pawn almost for sure I just wonder
if I can can go for more I mean I think
I can do this first simply try to be
annoying
[Music]
hmm okay age five minutes that's
approaching super strong territory well
why do I take it it's probably simpler
[Music]
he maybe have some some still meeting
saves but it gets tricky now anyhow
okay gotten more than I thought I would
get it still pursued wrong but he tried
really hard to lose this
I always feel it's really annoying if
they get a draw even though they played
it so we playing for loss and ascending
really really hard and probably had win
somewhere I'm fairly certain it was so
terrible what you did maybe there was a
wait a minute okay Kari is a winner
it just is made it's made said of f5
just was it I mean idiot just just it
resigns it's just just completely over a
window I mean it was I mean I'm not sure
how you can actually ever go to 83 I
mean this is just atrocious it but
anyway I mean okay it's still a draw but
but no nobody would go there I mean and
I put put yourself into a mating net but
anyhow okay so yeah that was a bit lame
not winning this yeah yeah both moves
are a good of course night big spontex
but context is really okay I just trade
out down to a position that is better
for black you know probably I should
need level out 95 but still it's the
reasonably solid and this is beyond just
the draw maybe night of course really
better night at for Quinn chief for him
you know this is just this is the ending
of the game which is of course it is
strictly a draw
he was really playing for loss and quite
quite
[Music]
yeah quite keen way yeah I really like
very important to win h1 yeah and this
is not winning here you cannot wait any
more
just the one moment just the one moment
yeah okay thanks for watching